bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir macron 2 les défis du
second quinquennat s'est officiellement
ce soir à minuit que commence le
deuxième mandat d' emmanuel macron et
pourtant l'impression d'un flottement
est là et bien là le président réélu n'a
toujours pas choisi son nouveau premier
ministre jean castex reste finalement à
matignon jusqu'à dimanche alors à quoi
joue le président de la république
peut-il se permettre d'attendre à
transmettre des législatives grand
décryptage dans un instant avec nos
invités notre grand témoin ce soir à
diriger radio france de 2014 à 2018 sa
nomination a aussitôt créé la polémique
sa direction virer au chemin de croix à
quoi s'est ajoutée pour pimenter le tout
la rumeur tenace d'une liaison cachée
avec emmanuel macron mathieu gallas dit
sa vérité dans jeux de pouvoir chez
bouquins il est avec nous ce soir enfin
nous retrouverons nos a franchi pour
leur parti pris est l'amour d'un gars va
bien sûr pour son carnet de campagne
quotidien sur des législatives les
dissidences en politique une vieille
histoire ce sera avec brandon ouaret et
delphine ça va tirer nous présenter un
nouveau réseau social sont pourtant en
français qui prône la vraie vie voilà
pour le même c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs macro 1 était un homme
pressé macron de prend au contraire tout
son temps mais pourquoi est-ce donc si
long quelle nouvelle équipe quelles
nouvelles méthodes le quinquennat qui
s'ouvre sera plus collectif a lâché le
porte parole gabriela talent mais
qu'est-ce que ça de bien vouloir dire on
se pose toutes ces questions ce soir
avec vous ça derrière jacques bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être là vous êtes
journaliste éditorialiste politique vous
collaborez notamment à france info et
vous venez de publier
résurrection quel titre vous nous
l'expliquer sans doute résurrection
c'est celle d'emmanuel macron vous avez
suivi dans les coulisses dans les
derniers mois de ce premier quinquennat
jusqu'à sa réélection c'est chez stock
bonsoir arnaud belletti est bienvenu
professeur associé à l'université paris
sorbonne rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire bonsoir
etienne gernelle bonjour ravis de vous
accueillir directeur de la publication
du point
dont le dernier numéro a déjà fait
couler beaucoup d'encre la vérité sur
mélenchon l'autre le pen ecrivez-vous en
une on en dira un petit mot qui on
parlera aussi de la précédente une
c'était c'était macron avec cette phrase
rappeler la noue mélenchon sors de ce
corps cette conférence publique le quoi
qu'il en coûte le passé lié un peu aux
défis qui l'attendent la directrice des
éditions de la revue regards quatre îles
tricot va nous rejoindre dans un instant
juste après le biais de valérie brochard
exceptionnellement ce soir qu'on est
ravi d'accueillir si j'ai bien compris
c'est à elle tout de suite
[Musique]
valérie vous nous planter le décor si
j'ai bien compris jean castex n'en finit
plus de dire au revoir alors si j'ai
bien compris mais rien ne c'était la
grosse bamboche 1 hier soir à matignon
des belles nappes des lumières tamisées
des applaudissements à faire trembler
les murs regardez ces images de marlène
schiappa tous les ministres étaient là
pour le pot de départ du monsieur un
tout au bout oui oui vous l'avez reconnu
ses lunettes en main quand il ne les
cherche pas sur son nez c'est jean
castex le futur ex premier ministre
alors dans les pots de départ vous
connaissez à la tradition fait toujours
un discours et dans celui de jean castex
il y avait beaucoup d'émotion je le cite
n'oubliez pas que nous sommes des
serviteurs l'action politique est une
action collective des fonctions ne sont
dus pour personne celui qui les quittent
doit ressentir de la reconnaissance à
l'heure après le discours peut pas la
falaise et mais après le discours la
fête un très bonne ambiance d'après mes
sources eric dupond moretti est même
venu avec son chien paraît-il et bien
évidemment pour un pot de départ il ya
toujours un cadeau de départ les
ministres ont choisi d'offrir à jean
castex un maillot et pas n'importe quel
maillot ici il est question de rugby
bien entendu c'est douelle numéro 9 est
ce que vous savez pourquoi le numéro 9
non personne ne sait
alors je vais vous le dire je vais vous
le dira bien parce que c'est le numéro
du demi-de-mêlée du quinze de france
antoine
absolument c'est l'un des meilleurs
joueurs au monde dont jean castex est
totalement fan alors on a écouté le
discours on a offert un maillot mais
myriam c'est quand même assez assez rare
de faire son pot de départ avant même de
donner sa démission c'est quand même un
drôle de départ aujourd'hui au moment où
on se parle jean castex est toujours le
chef du gouvernement et probablement
jusqu'à lundi prochain alors pourquoi
c'est si l'on a bien première
explication parce que l'annoncent du
premier ministre peut perturber la
campagne la campagne des élections
législatives plus tard en l'annoncent
mieux on se préserve seconde explication
peut-être qu'ils manuel macro ne l'a pas
encore trouvé peut-être qu'on maintient
jean castex jusqu'à la dernière minute
jusqu'à la dernière il dit qu'il a oui
c'est vrai en attendant d'avoir trouvé
là la perle rare le mouton à cinq pattes
qui saura diriger le prochain
gouvernement alors qu'ils première mais
les premiers ministres quels sont les
noms qui circulent myriam c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose
depuis des jours
qui sera le futur ou la futur premier
ministre est ce qu'on souhaitait qu'une
femme accède à matignon c'est le pot de
départ à matignon est toujours
l'incertitude sur qui va le remplacer
savez vous monsieur le président quel
premier ministre français occupera le
poste pour ce conseil des ministres
merci donc ce sera une femme mais j'en
sais rien
il en sait rien mais nous on aimerait
bien savoir on nous explique que dans
les ministères les cartons sont fait
rempli scotché il trépigne on trépigne
mais où est passé où est passé le
rouleau compresseur de 2017 les urgences
sont déjà là les prix du carburant
repartent à la hausse plus globalement
le pouvoir d'achat des français baisse
encore à l'international la situation
est toujours aussi tendue avec la guerre
en ukraine alors quoi alors quoi
emmanuel macron s'ils prouvent dans le
précédent quinquennat agir vite
intervenir vite faire vite prend t'il un
malin plaisir à faire monter la
mayonnaise at-il du mal à convaincre
peut-être que le poste m'intéresse plus
en tout cas vous le disiez un beaucoup
de noms circulent alors pourquoi pas un
homme un homme de la majorité une
affiche à richard ferrand françois
bayrou julien de normandie problème
problème myriam ce sont des hommes ce
sont des hommes et le président de la
république a plutôt laissé entendre
qu'il souhaitait une femme à la tête du
prochain gouvernement lors certaines ont
été approchés comme ils disent à berne
l'actuel ministre du travail marisol
touraine où audrey azoulay deux
anciennes un ministre deux oeuvres soit
hollande et oui oui un petit clin d'oeil
au parti socialiste ce serait bien aussi
en fait en fait si je comprends bien
pour dessiner le portrait robot de la
première ministre idéal emmanuel macron
en imaginant alors il imagine une femme
une femme de gauche à une femme de
gauche qui défendrait quand même la
retraite à 65 ans il faudrait qu'elle
soit techno mais pas trop plutôt
politique haussière mais sans faire de
l'ombre évidemment au président
consensuel sympathique mais qu'ils
sachent gérer les entreprises et les
cages et tout et tout l'opposition à
l'assemblée qui s'annonce corrosive et
ben voila voila je les trouvais voilà le
portrait robot de voilà du prochain de
la prochaine première ministre bon en
fait vous avez compris on n'en sait rien
on n'en saura rien avant l'annoncé
officielle et vous connaissez l'adage de
la macro ni un mur ceux qui parlent ne
savent pas et ceux qui savent ne parlent
pas merci beaucoup ouvert et vous allez
nous expliquer pourquoi c'est si l'on
est ce que c'est grave que ce soit s'ils
ont déjà
c'est pas grave non c'est pas grave ce
qui compte c'est de toute façon l'action
commencera réellement après des
législatives ce qui est normal des
équilibres politiques se font un sang
voilà donc non c'est pas grave et puis
tu te sens il fait toujours ça
maintenant on est toujours en retard une
caractéristique il
ya quinze ans elle était déjà comme ça
et c'est des idées toujours en retard il
est fini comme çà on a donc surtout sa
paillasse à dessein je pense que oui
c'est à dessein déjà il aime bien
prendre son temps il redevient le fameux
maître des horloges dont on a beaucoup
parlé au début du non mais c'est vrai
mais on a beaucoup parlé au début du
premier quinquennat par ailleurs réagir
sur la pression là ce qui est surprenant
c'est que c'est vrai qu'on se dit mais
franchement est ce qu'il y avait pas
pensé avant enfin eu le temps d'y penser
avant quand même au futur locataire de
matignon en fait je pense que c'est
quelqu'un pour l'avoir observé c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui réfléchit par
séquences dont il y avait des séquences
il ya eu la guerre en ukraine qui l'a
empêché d'entrer en campagne il ya eu
cette campagne extrêmement ramasser
extrêmement quand un rapide il ya eu ce
débat il n'y avait pas de voir
visuellement et maintenant il réfléchit
quatre séquences déjà un brassard et
l'ex médecin quand je vous dis que c'est
à dire c'est que je me demande si en ce
moment il se dit pas de tout ça sont
plus j'attends plus cette nouvelle
équipe c'est une image nouvelle avec qui
va insuffler quelque voilà qui va avec
un souffle mêlant un nouvel élan mais
qui va parler d'eux portait justement
jusqu'aux législatives en faudrait alors
c'est dans 3 semaines catherine très peu
importe bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes la directrice de la revue regards
l'élan et les portés par qui dans une
législative est normalement c'est celle
chef de la majorité donc le premier
ministre ben oui mais donc y en a pas il
n'ya pas d'élan il y avait déjà pas
d'élan à l'élection présidentielle
premier tour il rate quand même en gros
son entrée en campagne avec son
powerpoint est la seule annonce qu'on
retient c'est la retraite à 65 ans qui
n'emballe pas les français entre les
deux tours il est obligé de rétropédaler
de dire non mais finalement ce rapace ap
je vais concertée peut-être un
référendum et non pas de référendum mais
ce sera quand même la retraite à 65 ans
et je vais faire l'écologie etc etc donc
il nous brouille un peu les les cartes
et puis maintenant on est dans la
séquence législative normalement il faut
quand même qu il nous dise quelle est la
kz2 sa 2 futur quinquennat parce que le
problème s'est passablement connais pas
le premier ministre c'est qu'on ne
connaît pas le point d'équilibré
pourquoi on ne connaît pas le point d
équilibre parce qu'en fait au premier
tour dans sa campagne il n'a pas
finalement ferrailler pour imposer une
orientation et donc on ne la connaît pas
et il n'est pas élu
finalement au dos au second tour il est
lui aussi que dans un barrage contre
marine le pen donc il n'a pas on peut
pas dire qu'il a qui l'a complètement un
mandat clair et donc il va falloir qu'il
le définit une certaine manière et qu'il
me fasse bien nommé l'elysée c'est vrai
que c'est toujours politique le choix
d'un premier ministre même si on choisit
un techno il vient de quelque part on
quand même lui donner une certaine
coloration et surtout pour un deuxième
mandat avec les 22% de jean luc
mélenchon s'est bien fait au premier
tour ça doit être plutôt à votre avis un
profil de gauche sachant que la droite a
déjà voté macron dans cette es d'abord
il faut postuler peut-être qu'il n'est
pas aussi sûr de lui qu'on veut bien
croire je veux dire c'est à dire qu'il
faut pas penser que le président de la
république et quand bien même serait-il
élus maîtrise totalement la situation
moi ce que je pense fondamentalement
c'est que en effet je reviens je rejoins
ce qu'est ce qui a été dit c'est à dire
que il tarde à nouméa prémunissent ce
n'est pas très grave sur le fond parce
que en effet le quinquennat va commencer
après l'élection législative
c'est-à-dire après le fait qu'il y ait
une majorité en face ils arrivent à
disposer d'une d'une majorité aux
élections législatives mais finalement
la difficulté pour lui aujourd'hui il
s'est en effet à la fois de pouvoir
parler à son électorat de premier tour
qui n'est pas forcément l'électorat qui
a été celui au second tour enfin en tout
cas tout ou partie vous avez des
lectorats de second tour et vous l'avez
très bien dit qu'ils étaient nés
lectorat qui a fait barrage à marine le
pen qui est un électorat plutôt de
gauche dans son ensemble
le problème c'est qu'il faut qu'il
trouve un premier ministre qui soit
suffisamment équilibré pour parler à
l'électorat de premier tour qui est un
électorat plutôt réformiste qui souhaite
voir mettre en place un agenda qui n'a
pas forcément d'ailleurs été mis en
place durant le précédent quinquennat
mais il faut aussi qu'ils soient en
mesure de parler à cet électorat inquiet
socialement qui a voté pour lui je
rappelle quand même qu'il ya 42 % de
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon qui a
voté au second tour pour emmanuel macron
ce qui n'est pas négligeable donc il
faut aussi qu'ils soient en mesure de
s'adresser d'une certaine manière à cet
électorat donc l'exercice est compliqué
alors ensuite évidemment nommé premier
ministre dans la séquence que l'on
traverse est d'abord nommé celui qui va
mener là quand la
législative
ils se sont mis c'est ce que
m'expliquait récemment un projet
président ils sont mille l'explosion et
de 1 dans une seringue effectivement
avec cette histoire de nommer une femme
c'est à dire que maintenant comme ils
ont dit ou qu'ils ont fait savoir que
son lit et les mains le reste ce sont
les bas c'est sympa pour les femmes non
non mais que plus le temps passe plus il
sera difficile de faire autrement au
bout de trois semaines de sortir
finalement quelqu'un qu'il n'avait rien
à voir avec le portrait robot quand nous
dresse depuis depuis quelques jours et
juste pour terminer je pense que la
préoccupation de ces derniers jours du
président alors là on en sort ça
réellement été de s'assurer sa une
majorité solide les fameuses investiture
oblige à l'aller d une à une chaque ami
neil mac row est obsédé à l'idée d'agir
il considère que le premier quinquennat
ou en tout cas c'est vrai une grande
partie du premier quinquennat il a été
empêché d'agir par les gelées par la
crise et j'ai jaune par la pandémie
c'est 50 plus c'est pour agir pour
transformer les pays pour laisser une
trace s'il n'a pas une majorité solide
pour lui permettre d'agir la fameuse
anaphore du discours d'investiture il
répétait dix fois le monde derrière s'il
n'a pas cette majorité il ne pourra pas
effectivement réformer le pays donc
c'était vraiment sa préoccupation des
derniers jours il faut pas simplement
une majorité à l'assemblée il faut aussi
une majorité politique dans le pays or
le problème c'est que pour l'instant non
j'entendais qu'il a été élu mais n'a pas
été lui il a eu 28 pour son premier tour
il a il a eu 28 % l'institution non mais
attendez ce que je suis en train de vous
dire ce qu'il faut de majorité dans le
pays ce que je veux dire c'est que je
dis pas simplement être en position de
pouvoir il faut aussi s'il n'a pas pu
faire la réforme des retraites c'est
quand même parce qu'il a reçus une
opposition formidable dans pays et là il
peut se retrouver avec exactement la
même situation tous les saints non la
crise sanitaire l'a aidé à sortir de
ahmed stop à cette affaire mais on était
quand même depuis un an un an et demi
dans une crise sociale dans le pays qui
redoublait la caissette de la question
des gilet jaune donc ce que je veux dire
c'est que le problème c'est comme il n'a
pas convaincu au premier tour de
l'élection mais non au premier tour ça
la seule proposition qu'il fait c'est la
retraite aer mieux en nombre de voix non
attends qu il fait mieux en pourcentage
chantage si vous êtes totalisé les
tensions - le groupe que vous appelez
sert le groupe emmanuel macron plus le
groupe de droite si vous prenez entre
2017 et 2022 il s'écroule sert 2017 il
ya vingt ans et 20 ans en gros il enfin
21 et 28 26 à 21 heures il fait 41 42
hélas il ne fait plus que 28 et 5,33
c'est à dire qu'en fait le groupe de
droite s'est adressé au bénéfice
notamment de l'extrême droite mais
surtout ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il
n'a pas convaincu 70 % des français sont
opposés à la présence d'autres votre
analyse est clair qu'internet vous
réponds puis ensuite on avance parce
qu'on a pas
été votés en 1958 à 80 % des voix il a
gagné l'élection selon des règnes de
sont les règles démocratiques il est
légitime il a fait vrai dire il a les
moyens d'agir il a ok il ya aucun preuve
de ce que thales qui n'a pas convaincu
est ce que quelqu'un d'autre a convaincu
plus que lui réponse non il est
parfaitement légitime il a pas besoin
d'avoir de majorité dans le pays parce
que pardon dans l'histoire de france il
ya un président ça prend des initiatives
y compris de faire des choses qui ne
sont pas populaires est ce que de gaulle
était absolument certain quand il a
lancé le processus d'autodétermination
l'algérie qu'il avait la majorité du
pays derrière lui c'est pas sûr est ce
que parce que par exemple quand giscard
a fait libérer il était certain d'avoir
la majorité du haut risque
rapidement il ne faut pas confondre une
majorité politique et une majorité
social les blocages sociaux peuvent un
moment donné véritablement encalminé un
mandat et d'ailleurs je n'en veut clair
preuve la crise des gis les gens là
malgré tout d'une certaine manière
stopper la volonté réformiste d'emmanuel
ma console et pas seulement la crise
sanitaire qui l'a bloqué certes la crise
sanitaire a aussi fier phénomène mais la
crise la crise des gis les gens là quand
même jusqu'à s'en aller on ne sait pas
quand ccd
dit dès dimanche soir il va s'en aller
ça il l'a dit il le veut un petit bilan
quelques races il laissera on a
l'impression qu'il est irremplaçable aux
yeux de d'emmanuel macron ancrage local
techno tenait bien l'appareil d'état
c'est un peu tout ça c'est un peu tout
ça c'est la figure effectivement les
lieux au cal il ya même l'accent qui va
avec donc c'est vraiment la petite
touche en plus en même temps c'est un
très bon techno je rappelle qu'il avait
été secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée donc il a le côté effectivement
il connaît parfaitement les rouages de
l'état donc c'est ça c'est le côté très
bon gestionnaire il n'a pas fait d'ombré
à emmanuel macron tout en étant
populaire aucune ambition en avant
qu'une non mais vannes oc tallinn a
grandi à matignon à une rivalité elysée
matignon comme il a pu en avoir bien sûr
avec en tout cas sur la fin avec edouard
philippe tout ça fait qu emmanuel macron
je peux vous dire a réellement insisté
il a essayé de le faire rester en
touraine le vais rester au moins
jusqu'aux législatives ce que jean
castex n'a absolument pas voulu etienne
gernelle de bilan la trace castells mais
de toute façon tout ça c'est le bilan
des manuels macron le vrai sujet c'est
macron qu'il est premier ministre on
m'utilise affaires étrangères qui prend
aussi du temps c'est que le vrai premier
ministre
ça c'est un des vrais sujets pour lui
c'est arrivé à prendre un peu de
distance arriver à faire un peu de
chance il faut faire la méditation du
yoga ou quelque chose mais ne pas tout
faire seul lui-même expliqué gérard
collomb d'ailleurs dans le point il ya
biya la semaine dernière il est parfois
dans les sujets de stratosphérique ils
les planètes 6000 et puis dans les micro
détail est plus grand au milieu il ya
une couche d'organisation qui pèche un
peu et s'être classé matignon en grande
partie qu'ils doivent
pardon gérard collomb effectivement dans
l'intérêt qui est formidable qui
travaille à 100 at il dit pendant les
conseils des ministres lui en tant que
des intérieurs fait voilà un bilan on
oublie quelque chose et emmanuel macron
lui 2 litres relie toutes les notes
derrière pendant le conseil des
ministres effectivement mais est ce que
c'est vraiment nouveau sarkozy avait
déjà d'une certaine manière fait de son
premier ministre collaborateurs il ya un
cran supplémentaire est-ce qu'il a
complètement tué la fonction j'ai pas
s'il a tué
gomis mais on voit bien que de toute
façon il ya eu deux styles différents
avec ses deux premiers ministres en
train et loire philippe qui était un
premier ministre très politique parce
que lui aussi c'était un élu local mais
qui était quand même l'homme politique
qui était beaucoup plus visible que
l'avait été jean castex qui était quand
même élu d'une petite commune dans les
pyrénées-orientales s'était pas tout à
fait le même j'avais dire la même
dimension en termes j'allais dire de
jaillir de politisation et ce qui est
sûr c'est que si vous voulez
macron en effet il est dans le micro
management c'est à dire que c'est quand
même étonnant un président de la
république qui va réviser la liste de
tous les candidats qui sont investis aux
législatives très franchement
pas vraiment non ce détail la vie
réviser les 170 les 570 noms qui vont
être présentés dans chacune des
circonscriptions de france de navarre
des dom tom et de corps c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez exceptionnel par
exemple c'est quelqu'un qui reçoit
régulièrement enfin claire qui reçoit
régulièrement tout nouveau président
d'un établissement public ou d'une
administration ou directeur d'une
administration centrale qui est nommé
évolue par le président d'un public donc
si vous voulez ce cet art du détail
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
relève d'une forme de management qui
n'est pas tout à fait l'esprit de la
vème république de gaulle ne faisait pas
ça mitterrand ne faisait pas et même
nicolas sarkozy ne le faisait
vraisemblablement pas raymond évoque
maintenant je redonne la parole juste
après au fond sa feuille de route en
tout cas les chantiers qui l'attendent
sont très très nombreux s'il a une
majorité il va devoir s'attaquer vous le
savez en retraite à la planification et
écologique et beaucoup d'autres dossiers
tour d'horizon avec tivo inc
le pouvoir d'achat c'est la première
urgence que va avoir à gérer emmanuel
macron face à l'inflation un paquet de
mesures est annoncé pour le lendemain
les législatifs c'est les grandes
orientations d'un projet de loi de
finances rectificative qui sera présenté
dans la foulée des élections
législatives
au menu de cette loi une prolongation du
bouclier tarifaire sur l'électricité et
le gaz un dispositif de remises sur les
prix de l'essence un shack alimentaire
pour les plus modestes mais aussi un
triplement de la prime à kron une
revalorisation des retraites et minima
sociaux enfin la suppression de la
redevance télé passer l'urgence emmanuel
macron devrait alors s'attaquer au
travail de fond la réforme des retraites
devrait être examinée dès l'automne ou
l'hiver prochain il faudra de manière
concertée passé l'âge de notre retraite
à 65 ans le président qui a promis une
nouvelle méthode pour ce second
quinquennat ce chantier servira de test
emmanuel macron devra sortir d'un
exercice du pouvoir vertical et savoir
entendre les partenaires sociaux sur la
retraite à 65 ans le report de l'âge
légal la cfdt sera vent debout je lui
demande de mettre en oeuvre ce qu'il a
dit vous voulez changer de méthode
changer de méthode c'est de repartir du
réel une concertation qui s'avéra aussi
nécessaire pour un autre chantier majeur
la réforme des institutions
une commission transpartisane devrait
être mise en place pour plancher entre
autres sur la proportionnelle aux
législatives
le rétablissement du septennat et
l'éventuelle mise en place d'élections
de mi-mandat parmi les autres chantiers
prioritaires la planification écologique
qui seraient confiées au premier
ministre l'école justice ou encore le
grand âge autant d'ambitions qui risque
de coûter cher emmanuel macron
pourra-t-il dépenser sans compter comme
il l'a fait depuis la crise qu vide avec
la remontée des taux d'intérêt la dette
est une réalité qui risquent de
rattraper le président et de perturber
ses plans à partir de l'été je pense que
la banque centrale européenne relèvera
progressivement ses taux d'intérêts
l'illusion d'une dette qui est sans
limites et sans coûts c'est une illusion
très séduisante mais très dangereux pour
franchir tous ces obstacles le dernier
chantier d'emmanuel macron sera à
politique
le président devra pouvoir compter sur
une majorité solide et uni pendant cinq
ans pas forcément évident alors que la
bataille pour sa succession risque
d'aiguiser les appétits
alors on savait qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'état de grâce etienne gernelle mais là
on se demande s'il va pas au fond une
impasse d'entrée de jeu si je puis dire
les français attendent de nouvelles
mesures sur le pouvoir d'achat il ya
urgence on est à 5% d'inflation et en
même temps on entendait le gouverneur de
la banque de france qui va avec
christine lagarde probablement augmenter
les taux directeurs dans les semaines
qui viennent donc le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est fini comment faire déjà il je
pense qu'il faudrait arrêter de mentir
il ya un vrai sujet dans la politique
française il ya un vrai sujet dans la
société française de niveau d'économies
de connaissances en économie le pouvoir
d'achat en économie c'est extrêmement
simple le revenu des gens c'est un le
facteur du temps de travail et la
productivité si vous n'avez pas ça ça ne
le donne et faire des mesures du pouvoir
d'achat ce n'est que de faire des
transferts alors c'est possible on peut
le dire d on peut prendre aux uns et
donner aux autres données prendre aux
riches et donnés au
oui ou alors c'est faire du transfert de
génération se dire c'est ce d'après ils
vont payer en faisant de la dette donc
il faudrait commencer à dire une chose
c'est que si on veut augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat il faut augmenter leurs
revenus du pays basque de l'économie de
base 0 2% de croissance voilà donc la
question c'est comment est ce qu on
augmente la croissance comment est-ce
qu'on augmente l'emploi et la croissance
il a d'ailleurs lancé une du point c'est
du sérieux pour vous macro ont fait du
mélenchon 4 milliards déjà macro
ce bouclier est une boutade mais qui
rappelle quand même qu'il a alors pour
des bonnes raisons mais aussi un il y
avait une crise et ça a permis de
maintenir les moyens de production il a
dépensé énormément d'argent ce thème 600
milliards de dettes en plus ça n'est pas
rien il ya des raisons qu'il suffit de
lire et logistique vit très bien en dix
ans mais oui mais ce n'est pas fait ça
le l'appareil industriel se serait
effondré on aurait du mal à le
reconstruire oui ça se comprend mieux
maintenant on a un vrai sujet et
expliqué que l'étape déterminer des
revenus des gens c'est un mensonge pur
c'est
n'importe quoi de quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est plus possible il va falloir
forcément faire des investissements
moi avec l'écologie cette révolution qui
nous attend mais en même temps il ya un
énorme problème avec l'inflation qui
fait qu'on peut plus renchérir la dette
est-ce que ça c'est quelque chose qui a
évidemment bien dans tous les esprits en
plus haut niveau absolument se dire que
oui surtout quand c'est quelqu'un comme
bruno le maire qui tient les cordons de
la bourse ou quelqu'un comme alexis
colère effectivement c'est des gens qui
sont très conscientes c'est ce que toute
la campagne présidentielle c'est elle
reçoit deux candidats ont raser gratis
un peu absolument néanmoins certains
prennent un coup l'inquiétude des
manuels maire pense qu'il est vraiment
ce qui les préoccupe actuellement c'est
cette fracture dont on a qu on évoque
aussi cette fracture démocratique cette
fracture sociale est effectivement si on
ferme les robinets d'un seul coup sûr
les minima sociaux faire sur tout un tas
de chose est sûre notamment d'un des
maris ce qu'elle avait dit avec 5%
d'inflation un pouvoir d'achat
effectivement qui diminuent ils ont
extrêmement peur de ça donc il ya une
frontière qui est assez ténue alors de
quoi sorte de réveil de colère sociale
absolument la peur que effectivement le
la fracture actuelle entre ces deux
france que la france des gilets jaunes
ou des nouveaux gilet jaune se réveille
dans toute la question c'est
effectivement comment renouer le lien
est bien là aussi découle le chantier
démocratique de renouveau démocratique
c'est très important la réforme des
institutions mais là c'est autre chose a
renommé des laitiers on nous promet une
commission transpartisane les grands
élus ça prend du temps est-ce qu'on peut
résoudre la fracture démocratique
l'urgence avec une commission théodule à
la balladur qui me ferait des
propositions que dans les deux ans à
venir il est un vrai sujet s'il voulait
le vrai sujet il en est d'ailleurs
l'héritier parce que il n'en n'est pas
forcément responsable c'est la crise de
la représentation qui s'est installé
dans le pays depuis presque trois
décennies est donc dit quelque part il
est le co lysiane complètement avec la
crise des jeunes à chris dyson qui est à
l'origine crise sociale une crise
territoriale devient très rapidement une
crise politique puisque on va voir que
un certain nombre de revendications
institutionnelles vont se greffer sur
les revendications économiques
mais c'est une réalité elle exprime sa
élections qu'on le veuille ou non
présidentielle
2022 exprime aussi quelque part cette
fracture politique parce que c'est une
élection vous avez un taux d'abstention
qui est un taux d'abstention très
important qui est le plus important pour
une élection présidentielle depuis
depuis 1969 vous avez deux formations
politiques la france les a soumis et le
rassemblement national qui vont récolter
près de plus de 40% au second tour au
premier tour par tour de l'élection
présidentielle donc ça veut dire qu'il
ya quand même une des segments entiers
de l'opinion publique qui sont
aujourd'hui en sécession avec l'offre
politique matin est sélectionné à voter
avec le même scrutin
proportionnel a toujours été commise
manuel macron l'avait promis il ne l'a
pas réalisé lui non plus donc en effet
elle est de plus en plus urgente en
l'occurrence on voit bien que les
élections législatives vont se passer
avec le scrutin uninominal majoritaire
qui bien évidemment pas encore aussi
fier ce déficit de représentativité la
réforme institutionnelle et urgente en
effet mais elle ne réglera pas tout
parce que considéré qu' une réforme
institutionnelle va régler le problème
politique c'est pas c'est insuffisant il
ya aussi des offres politiques qu'il
faudrait qu'on dit un mot sur le dossier
chaud rouge écarlate c'est les retraites
on entendait laurent berger de la cfdt
cette fois ci vous pourrez pas faire son
nous monsieur le président c'est très
clair il nous parle d'une nouvelle
méthode est ce que vous y croyez est ce
qu'au fond le pays peut lui imposer ce
qu'on appelle le respect des corps
intermédiaires et je sais pas si on va
pouvoir lui imposer mais en tout cas je
pense que s'il ne veut passer en force
là il n'a pas énormément d'arguments
pour imposer sa réforme des retraites
dans la mesure où le corps dit c'était
que c'est un l'art et le système de
retraite sera l équilibre peu ou prou et
il n'est pas dans un grand déficit il
l'argument des ménages et la demande
dans l'est la demande émanait de mâcon
s'est dit je fais la réforme des
retraites pour pouvoir payer la réforme
de l'hôpital et la réforme de l'école
c'est à dire qu'en fait qu'il disait
c'est on va faire payer par un
prolongement de l'activité
les réformes dont nous avons besoin pour
notre pays donc à une solution qui est
celle d'emmanuel macron c'est celle là
vous avez dit emmanuel macron c'était
mélenchon ta mélenchon il proposait
passe à mélenchon a proposé nouvel
équilibre de la répartition des
richesses ces derniers ont bien c'est
des plus riches qui payent ou bien c'est
des salariés qui paye je le dis de
manière un peu cash mais en vérité
c'était ça la vérité l'alternative et
puis on dirait que la troisième c'était
celle de proposer marine le pen qui
était on va faire payer par les
étrangers donc il y avait trois
propositions sur comment on paye la
transformation du pays et emmanuel
macron l'idée sur ces les salariés qui
vont payer et notamment et notamment les
salariés qui ont commencé tôt leur
activité leur entrée dans le train alors
donc ça va être un très bon match elle
est indispensable on a compris pour vous
cette réforme des retraites vous avez vu
nous dire pourquoi mais qu'elle est
indispensable pour les équilibres
financiers du système parce qu'on nous
avait pris le nom mais je courais ce
qu'elle est indispensable pour donner
des gages à bruxelles pour pouvoir par
ailleurs si les deux c'est les deux elle
est indispensable financièrement de moi
je pense que les hypothèques du collier
de duke du corps d'ailleurs sont très
optimistes il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent l'inversé mais même même en
prenant les hypothèses du cor évidemment
qu'il est nécessaire et d'ailleurs
pourront pas garder choses très
simplement nous sommes le seul pays
d'europe le seul à garder une retraite
ne retraite ou si basses que ça et alors
est ce possible de trois questions est
ce qu'on vit moins vieux en france que
de jeunes est plus riche qu'elle est ce
qu'on est plus riche qu'en 1981 quand la
retraite est libre mais bon on est
beaucoup plus riche pourquoi son décès
il est moins bien aujourd'hui quand 80
commence pas à la retrait non d'une
différence de philosophie sans projet
sans qu'ils nous offrent aux gens qui
ont commencé à 18 ans 20 ans qui font
des métiers
et demie seconde répondre de dix
secondes tous les pays d'europe se
comporte normalement regarde il regarde
ce qui se passe le pays bas par exemple
fait indexés sur l'espérance de vie il
faut prendre des choses très simples
faut pas faire croire aux gens ont
blessé la fierté du travail de monsieur
la france est un des pays d'europe et
même peut-être le pays d'europe où la
productivité du travail est le plus
élevé maintenant je vais vous expliquer
parce qu'elle plus de chomage d'accord
j'ai remonté la productivité il fallait
monter le chômage c'est vachement les
grandes économies de
productivité du travail est tellement
élevé est tellement élevé que les gens
sont excusés de cheval aucun problème
non je vous réponds productivité est
plus forte en france parce qu'on y
travaille moins c'est aussi simple que
ça on travaille moins qu'ailleurs est ce
que c'est possible non y arriver là
qu'il faudra la difficile ça vous vous
en doutez vous voulez jeter et je ne
sais pas ce qui manquerait aura le
courage de le faire ça je n'en sais rien
et c'est ça la gronde la grande
incertitude est ce que macro aura du
courage ou pas
sur le courage rappelons-nous au
lendemain du premier tour est ce qui
nous a tous surpris première sortie au
lendemain du premier tour au contact à
amender l'âge de départ c'est vraiment
première chose qu'ils annoncent ils
annoncent que aouissi ce tête ça ne m'a
pas peut-être 64 voilà donc aura-t-il le
courage viendrait faire une question
juste pour vous répondre mais maintenant
sur la méthode effectivement moi j'ai
changé avec quelqu'un qui est un pige la
majorité avec qui l'échangé il essaie de
le convaincre de ça ils ne croient pas
effectivement si blocage il y à un haut
niveau de du parlement au niveau de
l'assemblée nationale l'idée d'un il
pousse l'idée d'un référendum c'est à
dire qu'après les retraites sur les
retraites dans l attente est risqué
mais qui passeraient sur les retraites
parce qu'après tout voilà macron une
majorité il vient d'être réélu donc une
majorité de français serait assez censé
selon re pour voter en faveur petite
majorité relative à lui tente qu'ils le
trouvaient déjà le maire a dit - c'est
une question complexe comme la
définition se dit
manuel macro et il aime tout ce qui est
effectivement à contre 1 contre 8 voix
c'est peut-être une exception même si on
m'a trouvé référendum sur les retraites
pas du tout à cette hypothèse du
référendum parce que il sait très bien
que le référendum c'est une prise de
risque excessive au regard finalement de
ce qu'ils souhaitent faire en
l'occurrence mais moi je pense que ce
qui va déterminer pardon du blocage
social
je pense malheureusement des glaces et
que les politiques français sont
vaccinés du référendum depuis le
référendum de 2005 entre autres qui a
quand même manifestement secoué la
classe politique française et qui n'a
d'ailleurs pas été respectée puisque le
traité de lisbonne a réintroduit quand
même il faut le rappeler les principales
dispositions du traité qui avait été
rejeté par les français qui explique
vraisemblance il a crise de défiance
d'une partie de l'opinion publique
vis-à-vis de l'offre politique mais je
pense que ce qui va déterminer tout ça
c'est le résultat d'élections
législatives tout dépend de la majorité
qu'il va obtenir si la une jory t large
s'il a une majorité absolue comme il
souhaite le faire il va certainement
essayer de mener dans les premières
semaines de son mandat après le pouvoir
ordinaire qui constitue un marqueur on
le voit bien qu'ils sont
évidemment il le fera mais il a besoin
d'aller vite sur ce sujet là parce que
c'est un sujet où son électorat attend
des gestes très forts et donc faire vite
et bien on va s'arrêter là merci
beaucoup merci pour vos analyses on a
fait un beau tour d'horizon
personnellement j'ai apprécié ce moment
vous êtes bienvenu quand vous voulez on
va à présent accueillir notre grand
témoin il a dirigé radio france de 2014
à 2018 sa nomination a aussitôt créé la
polémique sa direction virer au chemin
de croix à quoi s'est ajoutée pour
pimenter le tout la rumeur tenace d'une
liaison cachée avec le futur chef de
l'état mathieu gallet dit sa vérité dans
jeux de pouvoir et nous rejoint dans un
instant juste après ce sujet marc au
pommier
si on vous invite mathieu gallet c'est
pour parler de la trajectoire
balzacienne d'un provincial monté à
paris ces mots ce sont les vôtres vous
l'ancien dirigeant de l'audiovisuel
public dans votre livre jeux de pouvoir
vous raconter votre parcours votre
ascension
après une longue période de silence
pourquoi maintenant parce que je voulais
laisser passer le temps parce que très
vite su passer aussi à autre chose en
créant magellan cette plate forme de
podcasts et puis c'était un témoignage
que je voulais apporter un témoignage
personnel c'est un témoignage aussi sur
les moeurs parfois politique et celle
des médias ce monde politico médiatique
vous l'avez côtoyé mathieu gallet
d'abord en tant que conseiller dans les
cabinets ministériels sous jacques
chirac et nicolas sarkozy
vous devenez ensuite président pas de la
république mais de l'ina à la tête de
radio france entre 2014 et 2018 vous
affrontez la plus longue grève de
l'histoire de l'institution
28 jours de contestation sur fond de
restrictions budgétaires décidées par le
gouvernement socialiste
motion de défiance a été voté pour que
mathieu gallet quitte l'entreprise
mathieu gallet n'est plus reconnu comme
un président pour les par les salariés
de radio france vos années passées à
radio france vous y revenez largement
dans votre livre tout comme sur les
pressions et l' ingérence du pouvoir
politique à votre égard sans oublier
votre condamnation par la justice 30000
euros d'amendé pour favoritisme
alors que vous étiez à la tête de l'ina
quant à cette prétendue liaison
amoureuse avec emmanuel macron qualifié
cette rumeur de dégueulasse dégueulasse
boules puantes de la campagne
présidentielle de 2017 à l'époque le
candidat tente de démonter ce bruit de
couloir avec une
[Applaudissements]
aussi du blé
[Musique]
alors mathieu gallet vous qui êtes
restés silencieux sur votre histoire
pendant des années pourquoi ce besoin
d'écrire aujourd'hui et en reparlant de
cette rumeur avec emmanuel macron ne
prenez vous pas le risque de la relance
et à vous la parole
bonsoir mathieu gallet merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes le président
de la plateforme podcast que de podcasts
magellan que vous avez créé vous signez
donc jeux de pouvoir la vérité sur une
affaire politico-médiatique cc chez
bouquins qu'est ce qui au fond vous êtes
décidé à écrire cette histoire il ya la
difficulté des années difficiles à radio
france mais il ya aussi et surtout parce
que vous commencez par par ce chapitre
sur 7 sur cette rumeur pour rebondir sur
le sujet de marco pommiers en reparler
c'est la remettre au fond ou allah dans
l'actualité en tout cas c'est évidemment
qu'une rumeur mais qu'est ce qui a
déclenché cette envie d'écrire ce qui
m'a donné envie d'écrire quand je revois
votre sujet et je revois des images je
n'avais pas vu depuis l'époque c'est de
voir aussi ce changement entre mon
arrivée à radio france on le voit une
tension parce qu'il ya une réforme
lourde importante qui est à conduire et
que par ailleurs le gouvernement
l'époque coupe 20 millions d'euros en
parlèrent 4 millions de dotations il ya
cette crise etc les souvenirs de mon
départ de radio france et ça vous est
pas les images mais où les gens sont
debout dans le grand auditorium de radio
france en train de m'applaudir et donc
je le dis dans le livre finalement roxy
à écrire à votre mère on me rend vos
amis au président fait on reconnaît au
fond ce que j'ai fait on reconnaît mon
action la transformation que j'ai fait à
radio france à la fin de ces quatre
années de mandat qui ont été chahutées
et au fond je suis rentré avec des
regards suspicieux sur ce jeune homme de
37 ans qui venait d'arriver et je suis
parti sous les applaudissements
unanime de l'équipe de radio france 2
avec ça me touche de revoir ces images
et c'est justement pour ça j'ai voulu
laisser passer le temps je voulais pas
réagir à chaud on m'a proposé en 2018
quand je suis parti d'écrire un livre je
vais passer très vite à autre chose avec
magellan vous l'avez rapide raconter
c'est aujourd'hui ma vie d'entrepreneur
avec cette plate forme de podcasts qui
aura bientôt trois ans donc en fait je
suis parti dans autre chose très vite je
me suis rappelé le bon moment et alors
c'est le bon moment parce que d'un le
procès en appel est passé il ya un an
maintenant pour moi c'est très important
ma peine a été très fortement allégé
j'ai été relaxé pour la moitié des faits
qui m'étaient reprochés à une viande un
contrat qui datent et l'ina vous le dit
effectivement ma mère m'a dit si tu
écris patio dit que je ferais à ta place
donc il est bon il vaut mieux que ce
soit quand même moi qu'ils écrivent et
puis chez pai a eu un moment le temps
d'un été l'été dernier j'étais chez
régis wargnier le réalisateur
d'indochine qui était un ami faisait
mauvais puisqu'on est en bretagne il
pleuvait et je lui parle et on revenait
de ses sur ses souvenirs il m'a dit mais
tu devrais écrire ce livre et c'est vrai
que j'ai commencé à mettre mon
ordinateur et j'ai commencé le livre à
ce moment là on propose même d'en faire
une série vous nous direz tout à l'heure
si vous êtes si vous êtes juste pour le
faire cette rumeur elle a enflé en 2017
pendant les mois qui ont précédé
l'élection présidentielle elle vous
prêtait une liaison avec emmanuel macron
elle a pris une ampleur délirante elle a
largement dépassé les frontières du
parisien à tel point d'ailleurs que
votre tante à la rochelle est obligé de
démentir votre grand mère aussi soit
quand emmanuel macron dit à bobino
veulent abus sur les dents le sujet si
dans les boucles de mails on vous dit je
suis en couple avec mathieu gallet
effectivement ma propre grand mère qui à
80 ans à l'époque a reçu ce type de mail
et je le raconte dans le livre elle
m'appelle injouable des coûts de mon
chéri j'ai reçu remet bizarre on dit
qu'il ya des photos qui vont sortir de
toi avec emmanuel macron donc c'était
vraiment une rumeur qui n'est pas une
rumeur parisienne qui d'abord été une
rumeur effectivement de dîners en ville
mais quand je me suis rendu compte au
cours de l'année 2016 que vraiment c'est
aller partout y compris à
l'international puisque je le raconte
aussi on est avec mon équipe
dans la silicon valley en californie en
février 2017 ces quinze jours à peu près
après que emmanuel macron à traiter de
la rumeur
robin ovale avec humour avec
l'hologramme la référence à à mélenchon
on arrive chez google puisque ont visité
toutes les grandes entreprises de l'ateq
californienne et là on voit les
occurrences de recherche autour de radio
france mathieu gallet emmanuel macron
qui ont explosé dans le monde entier
donc il y avait vraiment un sujet à
traiter moi je n'étais que l'instrument
de cette rumeur le laissait pas vous
casser la rumeur de la question on sait
aujourd'hui par exemple que des médias
russes comme secouèrent telle ont
alimenté il ya eu vraiment une forme
d'utilisation très politique de cette
rumeur et c'est le candidat qui lui tord
le coup c'était lui la cible moi j'étais
l'instrument c'était lui la cible parce
que certains pensé et je le dis dans le
livre parce que j'ai conduit aussi un
peu mon enquête d'où venait cette rumeur
parce qu'il manuel et macro et moi on
n'est pas amis on s'est vus 4,5 fois
peut-être c'est une relation
professionnelle il était secrétaire
général adjoint de l'elysée puis
ministre de l'économie moi j'étais à li
na ensuite j'étais à radio france mais
c'était pas un ami donc c'est pas
quelqu'un sur qui on peut raconter une
histoire & broad et j'ai envie de dire
c'est vraiment une création à partir de
rien donc il ya bien quelqu'un qui
l'inventé vous avez fait votre enquête
moi j'ai fait mon échec c'est pouvoir
survivre effectivement du journaliste
d'investigation marquant d'evel qui en
2020 avait déjà ouvert quelques pistes
sur ce sujet moi je pense que ça vient
effectivement du camp socialiste du camp
de l'époque emmanuel macron ceux qui ont
vu que emmanuel macron devenait un
danger pour leurs propres ambitions
puisqu'il avait décidé de se lancer pour
lui-même donc moi je pense était très
bien que lui tordre le cou à la rumeur
avec humour et que moi finalement ben
voila j'ai pris le temps
de passer à autre chose et aujourd'hui
je voulais quand même dire ma vérité
parce que c'est quelque chose qui m'a
blessé aussi c'est quelque chose qui est
à blesser aussi dans mon couple puisque
moi aussi j'ai une vie personnelle je
comprends que c'est aussi blessé
brigitte macron parce que au fond c'est
quand même on vient salir à compter dé
des cochonneries des inventions au
prétexte que effectivement on peut
m'aurait pas imaginer qu'un homme plus
jeune ne soit avec une femme plus âgée
parce que donc derrière tout ça la magie
ni misogyne homophobe et donc il ya
quelques personnalités politiques qui
pensaient pouvoir empêcher aux candidats
d'accéder à la magistrature suprême en
raconter en ce genre de bêtises et et en
même temps on sent que vous êtes plutôt
satisfait de la manière dont finalement
emmanuel macron on a fini avec cette
rumeur qui tue s'est dégonflé très vite
vous voulez on voulait de ne pas vous
avoir prévenus c'est ça moi j'aurais
préféré qu'ils m'appellent effectivement
ou m'envoie un message juste avant
puisque j'apprends comme tout le monde
je suis dans un dîner avec quelques amis
notamment avec le maire de marseille à
l'époque jean paul jean claude gaudin
c'est une scène que je relate dans le
livre et je sens que mon bon portable
vibre dans ma veste et je vois les
messages qui tombe sur twitter et tout
ça et effectivement et moi je découvre
c'était bien qu'il le fasse c'est vrai
que j'aurais préféré qu'il me le dise ah
bon mathieu gallet vous venez de la
droite vous ne vous en cachez pas vous
en parler dans le livre ce sont vos
valeurs vous avez travaillé dans des
cabinets ministériels des gouvernements
de jacques chirac et de nicolas sarkozy
à la culture avec frédéric mitterrand
quand vous êtes nommé à 37 ans d'entrée
de jeu en 2014 a raté le français la
polémique elle elle va finalement pas
s'arrêter cette polémique lors d'autres
la france d'être le pouvoir en tout cas
socialiste de l'époque n'a jamais
vraiment accepté cette nomination par le
csa à l'unanimité oui parce qu'en fait
je suis effectivement j'ai ce parcours
en cabinet ministériel avec christine
albanel puis avec frédéric mitterrand et
donc je suis marqué à droite et j'arrive
nommé à l'unanimité par le csa qui est
présidée par olivier schrameck ancien
directeur de cabinet de lionel jospin
m'a timan de gauche voilà c'est la
gauche c'est françois hollande qui a
décidé de redonner au csa le pouvoir de
nommer les dirigeants de diviser public
et la ministre la culture de l'époque
aurélie filippetti jour de mon élection
mme envoie un sms sec
bonne chance à peu près donc c'est vrai
que d'entrée on n'est pas en zone en
tout cas de confiance vous diriez que le
pouvoir vous a mis des bâtons dans les
roues dentées le début vous aviez des
économies à faire vous vous lavez
présenté il ya eu une grève de 28 jours
elle n'est pas très surprenante 20
millions d'euros c'est beaucoup c'est
plus que ce que vous pensiez devoir
avoir affaire au départ mais jamais le
pouvoir socialiste ne vous a soutenu
vous dit même que manuel valls vous a
poussé à la démission pendant la grande
grève de 28 jours oui le premier
ministre manuel valls où est mon départ
la ministre leur pèlerins elle aussi
puisque au fond cette crise personne n'a
vu venir et donc il ya bien quelqu'un
qui doit porter le chapeau entre la
ministre et le dirigeant il ya eu en
tout cas un faisceau d'hostilité à la
fois en interne parce qu'effectivement
on certains syndicats cela il suit plus
tard à servir au bureau
le pouvoir l'a prêté des travaux des
arbitres en euros décidée avant mon
arrivée mais se trouve qu'ils ont été
faits pendant que j'étais président de
radio france et heureusement
l'inspection des finances dans son
rapport me blanchira de ce reproche mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya un climat qui est
pas un climat de confiance en revanche
ce que tout le monde voit très vite
c'est que les résultats sont là c'est là
que dès la rentrée 2014 les audiences
monte et n'ont cessé de monter tout au
long de ma présidence et au fond ma
satisfaction ma fierté aujourd'hui c'est
de voir que ce que j'ai mis en place à
l'époque les grilles de programmes et
personne qui dirige aussi les antennes
ce sont encore les mêmes et les succès
aujourd'hui de radio france ils viennent
de cette époque ils ont été prolongées
par l'équipe qui m'a semaine mais ce
livre c'est aussi est le récit des
pressions politiques sur les médias oui
rappelez vous les avez subi directement
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron va supprimer
la redevance vous avez écrit une tribune
dans le monde pour manifester vos
inquiétudes voire vos risques est ce que
l'audiovisuel public son indépendance
est menacée avec cette réforme
l'audiovisuel public je pense qu'avec
cette suppression de la redevance qui
est confirmé par le gouvernement cette
semaine doit partir du mois de septembre
va devoir se réinventer et c'est un peu
ce que je dis aussi à la fin du livre on
a eu de très beaux projets au cours de
mes quatre années de mandat radio france
notamment le projet
france info télé avec delphine ernotte
nous avons fait avec delphine ernotte
aujourd'hui on doit aller plus loin mais
je pense que la pression qui va être sur
les budgets de diviser le public doivent
le conduire à se réformer moi je suis
pour aujourd'hui une entreprise unique
de l'audiovisuel public qui regrouperait
la radio la télé le national et
l'international pour pouvoir être plus
forts face à résister aux plates formes
américaines et aussi au géant français
privé que vont être le groupe tf1 m6 rtl
où le groupe autour de canal+ ou d'altis
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'avoir une taille critique et on a
besoin aussi de repenser le
fonctionnement de l'audiovisuel en
général de l'usaid puis en particulier
pour tenir compte de la jeunesse parce
que le plus grand danger aujourd'hui
pour les médias traditionnels
c'est que les jeunes ne regarde plus
n'écoute plus la radio ne regardent plus
la télévision et ça c'est un enjeu pour
moi de souveraineté c'est un ange et de
civilisation on sent que vous avez
encore le goût voilà des jo reste je
reste des médias et de la gestion au
niveau vous vous pensez pouvoir
retravailler dans un média publie
aujourd'hui je suis dans mon aventure
entrepreneuriale ce qui est sûr c'est
que mes convictions pour les médias la
vision que je peux avoir je la partage
dans ce livre et voilà aujourd'hui j'ai
ma liberté
pour pouvoir le tien et ça deviendra une
série comme le veut on verra ce que
c'est très évident c'est vrai en tout
cas si vous avez
de donner du rythme et pourquoi pas une
série peut-être un jour ben on verra
savourer invitera pour la série alors
merci mathieu gallet merci d'être venu
sur le plateau de lcp c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos a franchi pour leur
parti pris à présent comme chaque soir
on retrouve à elsa mon magasin pour son
carnet de campagne sur les législatives
brandt de noir être ce vendredi soir va
revenir en archives sur les dissidents
dans notre histoire politique et puis
des tuiles sabatier va nous parler d'un
nouveau réseau social 100 % français qui
cartonne aux affranchis les voici merci
à vous on aurait pu garder mathieu
gallet
n'est pas forcément partir tant pis il
était très pressé alors on va commencer
avec vous l arbre vous nous parler ce
soir dans votre chronique les 577 de
quoi donc des élections du 12 et du 19
bien sûr celui qui veut être premier
ministre jean luc mélenchon ce soir il a
donné rendez vous à ses partisans dans
sa circonscription dans le sud de la
france la quatrième circonscription des
bouches-du-rhône à marseille voilà
c'était hier soir myriam n'y avait pas
vraiment d'où temps il l'avait déjà dit
jean luc mélenchon il voulait pas
forcément revenir ici au palais bourbon
à part en tant que premier ministre mais
pas entendre députés et donc il est il a
donné rendez vous hier soir à ses
partisans et ce qui est bien avec jean
luc mélenchon assez bas il fait les
questions et réponses
alors monsieur mélenchon pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas candidat à la législative
que c'est bon parent qui va être
candidat
[Applaudissements]
devant le conflit
bompard ces manuels bompard c'est un
fidèle c'était son directeur de campagne
sur toutes les photos toutes les vidéos
il n'est jamais très loin du chef c'est
lui qui a mené il ya quelques jours les
négociations pour aboutir à un accord de
toute la gauche alors il a ses chances
dans sept circuits ce que jean luc
mélenchon a recueilli plus de 54% des
voix un mathématicien d'ailleurs de
formation manuel bompard comme cédric
villani s'amène à la politique
finalement alors on parle à présent elsa
de la majorité vous nous parler gros
sous ce soir parce qu'il faut avoir bien
en tête que c'est des élections
législatives sont très importantes pour
le financement des partis politiques oui
tout à fait c'est le score des candidats
aux élections et puis ensuite c'est le
nombre de députés à la fin qui vont
déterminer le financement sur les sommes
que vont toucher les partis politiques
en tout ça représente plus de 60
millions par an tous partis confondus
est bien dans la majorité on a décidé
myriam de fer compte commun
[Musique]
alors écoutez cette phrase de françois
bayrou lors de la conférence de presse
la semaine dernière on était tous un peu
occupé sur la politique mais les
finances a son importance écoutez nous
sommes accordés sur une association de
financement unique qui fait qu'il n'y
aura pas de concurrence entre nous alors
effectivement l'argent ça reste parfois
le nerf de la guerre pour cette union
donc entre la république en marche le
modem et horizons et bien les époux
puisqu'on a bien vu qu'il s'agissait
d'un mariage n'a été entre eux et elles
ont rédigé un contrat de mariage parfois
ça peut être signe que des gens se
méfient un peu des uns des autres alors
chaque candidat de la majorité sera
rattaché à ensemble majorité
présidentielle est pas à la république
en marche bientôt renaissance modem ou
horizons tout l'argent public sera mis
au pot commun et ensuite du mans
répartis entre en fonction du nombre de
voix et ensuite du nombre de députés si
un des potiers décide de changer de
groupe en cours de mandat déjà il faudra
l'accord des trois parents des trois
présidents de groupe et son financement
lui il ne bougera pas manière de dire eh
bien que c'est figé au moins pour cinq
ans mais vous savez myriam en politique
comme en amour au début on pense tous
que c'est pour la vie une fois sur deux
ça se termine en divorce mais il faut
regarder le contrat de mariage parce que
parfois c'est compliqué de divorcer
merci merci beaucoup est là on continue
à parler des législatives avec vous
brandon on va parler des dissidences
alors c'est c'est pas très nouveau mais
on voit que la avec la nuque la nouvelle
coalition de toute la gauche il va y
avoir des socialistes qui n'ont pas été
investis par jean luc mélenchon et les
autres partis dans cette alliance qui
vont partir en dissidence les
dissidences c'est une très vieille
histoire elle laisse véritablement au
lendemain de la présidentielle de 1965
au moment où le général de gaulle se
retrouvant en ballotage au second tour
face à françois mitterrand forcément ça
va provoquer des frictions dans le camp
gaulliste pour les législatives de 1967
alors forcément le premier ministre
confie dont réagit
supposer un loup qui est malade dans le
money belle médecin va le soigner il va
le traiter avec la péniche la
pénicilline ça provoque des petits
inconvénients par exemple d éruption de
boutons
agréable ça démange seulement laguérie
la pneumonie est bien en politique
la diversité des parties la multiplicité
des candidatures est une des maladies de
notre pays
absolument alors c'est surtout à partir
des années 2000 que les candidats
dissidents vont occuper massivement le
terrain des et en 2002 françoise de
panafieu va semer la zizanie au sein de
l'ump elle est députée maire du xviie
arrondissement de paris elle a reçu le
feu vert de son parti pour les
législatives alors jusque là pas de
problème sauf que elle se sent menacée
dans sa circonscription d'origine alors
elle va se porter candidates dans une
autre circonscription
le xviie arrondissement est grand comme
la ville de metz et c'est absolument cas
comme si on allait demander au maire de
metz d'être des pétés de thionville ça
n'est pas possible même circonscription
était à cheval sur le 18e arrondissement
pour plus d'un tiers comment aller
expliquer aux électeurs du xviiie
arrondissement de le maire du xviie
arrondissement va s'occuper d'eux en
plus de remporter la circonscription
face à bernard pense qu'il est quand
même à l'époque l'un des plus proches
collaborateurs de jacques chirac
françoise de panafieu pousse son
adversaire la retraite qui quitte la vie
politique française et en même temps
elle réintègre son giron d'origine alors
ça c'est gagnant gagnant tous tous les
décideurs n'ont pas cette chance de
pouvoir revenir dans leurs familles
rappelez-vous du parti socialiste de
2012 en charente-maritime candidats à la
rochelle olivier falorni bascule dans la
dissidence lorsque la patronne de la
région poitou charentes obtient à la
rochelle l'investiture officielle du
parti socialiste c'est d'abord une
candidature de résistance de résistance
contre ce parachutage imposé contre ce
coup de force antidémocratique et une
mauvaise nouvelle n'arrive jamais seule
pour la candidate c'est la double peine
pour ségolène royal puisque à quelques
jours du second tour valérie trierweiler
qui est à l'époque la compagne de
françois hollande publie ce tweet ou à
découvrir ensemble on s'en souvient tous
oui alors vous pouvez y aller courage à
olivier falorni qui n'a pas démérité
alors ce règlement de comptes médiatique
va forcément accentué la victoire
d'olivier chaleur d'ailleurs ensuite
exclu à l'assemblée nationale du parti
socialiste il ne sera d'ailleurs jamais
réintégrer à droite aussi les
dissidences font entendre c'est le cas
notamment d'henri guaino il y avait
l'épisode de thierry solère en 2012 qui
s'était présenté dans la circonscription
face à claude guéant henri guaino lui
n'a pas été investi par les républicains
parce qu'il avait critiqué à de
nombreuses reprises françois fillon
durant la campagne présidentielle de
2017 alors lui henri guaino il va faire
4 % c'est le monsieur 4% et c'est le
genre de mauvais joueurs qui une fois
éliminé bas vis de tout son sac
l'électorat
qui a voté dans la pro 2e
circonscription de paris aujourd'hui
dans le 6e arrondissement le cinquième
et une partie du 7e est à mes yeux à
venir à vomir vous entendez bien six ans
qu'il ya des bobos je peux pas en parler
dans l'antre soin de leur égoïsme puis
espèce de bourgeoisie traditionnelle de
droite c'est celle qui va à la messe qui
envoie ses enfants au catéchisme puis
après qu'ils votent pour un type qui
parle en 30 ans s'est arrangé à tricher
être dissidents ne portent pas toujours
chances de la vue puisque henri guaino
après cette défaite quittera
définitivement la vie politique car
series et son propre électorat j'avais
jamais vu j'avais jamais vu ça merci
beaucoup bon on verra si les dissidents
de 2022 entreront dans l'histoire
l'actualité numérique avec delphine tab
etc pour terminer vous souhaitez attirer
ce soir notre attention sur un réseau
social français gros carton qui prône la
vraie vie je vais vous changer les idées
avec une autre histoire alors c'est
intéressant sur ce que ça dit de la
société numérique et aussi d'une quête
d'une certaine authenticité plus ou
moins sincères on va commencer déjà par
le succès de ce réseau social dont qui
s'appelle bio soit vrai si on traduit en
français et c'est ni chinois ni
américain mais français alors c'est une
vraie première surprise parce que on dit
que c'est déjà la nouvelle attraction
jusque sur les campus universitaires de
grande bretagne et des etats unis
harvard notamment qui est le berceau on
sait de facebook alors bis riols s'est
même hissé au top des classements de
l'app store on le voit en quatrième
position fin avril c'est publié à
l'origine par elon musk dans un trou ce
qui permet aux jeunes fondateurs
français de lui faire un petit clin
d'oeil et non un elon pour info cette
appli n'est pas à vendre l'autre
curiosité c'est que bio se présente
comme un anti ainsi g l'idée là c'est
vraiment se montrer sous son vrai jour
sans fard sans préparation alors comment
ça marche concrètement donc on reçoit
tous les jours une notification de
l'application mais alors on ne sait pas
à quelle heure lorsqu'elle arrive donc
on est à l'improviste et bien on n'a que
deux minutes là pour activer son
appareil photo et l'application va
prendre automatiquement deux clichés
c'est à dire qu'on va avoir deux images
d'un côté ce qui se trouve face à nous
et de l'autre côté notre visage en selle
vie autrement dit en dévoile et bien les
deux facettes de notre moment de vie un
côté on est vraiment à part sans
vraiment ok j'ai compris ce passe en
face de nous et ce qu'on est vraiment l
on peut en plus pas du tout a ajouté
deux filtres et il n'est pas la question
la de
conduire une avalanche de postes sur le
réseau puisque les notifications ne
tombe qu'une seule fois par jour et donc
elles ne peuvent pas être truqué ses
photos c'est un peu un acte militant
vous diriez ça oui alors ça repose
clairement tout cas sur une comme une
réaction une opposition je dirai au
déversement qui sont coutume donc ouzou
coutumier pardon les influenceurs sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est une réaction
aussi aux diktats de la perfection ou en
tout cas de la bonne attitude à avoir
des fake comme on dit sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est aussi le moment de
rappeler tous ses effets toxiques un des
réseaux sociaux des documents internes
qui avaient été révélées par la lanceuse
alerte française sous dun donc ex
employé de facebook témoignaient qu en
angleterre par exemple sur 21 % d'ados
qui ont pensé à se faire du mal voire à
se suicider 22% disent que c'est arrivé
à cause d'un stade g donc là avec berrer
all évidemment ce qui séduit c'est le
côté au naturel de ces photos impromptue
mais alors s'il s'agit plus de rêver
l'avis des autres un qui n'est pas au
quotidien extraordinairement drôle
génial ou horribles bien parfois ça peut
sembler même un terrible ennuis alors on
se demande à quoi bon c'est pour ça que
vous avez été épargnés aujourd'hui de ma
photo du jour qui n'avait aucun intérêt
à dommage j'aurais bien très intéressés
l'autre question que pour moi ça marche
alors c'est une autre question que pose
justement presque malgré elle cette
application by riial c'est pourquoi
autant ce besoin nécessaire d'exposer
notre vie au quotidien qu'est ce qui à
d'authentiqués véritablement là dedans
alors moi personnellement je suis très
peu sur les réseaux sociaux donc je vous
pose la question à 100 vous traitent en
tête des six géants de rio est quand
même pour me préparer à vérifier où je
suis et c'est à deux minutes ça va ça
laisse quand même le temps préparé les
deux plans sert le sien plus celui d'en
face et tous la marche très fort j'irai
chez les plus jeunes ça marche très fort
ça marche très fort pas qu'en france
c'est ça vraiment la grande surface
qu'aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux c'est
quoi ces tic toc instagram facebook
c'est que les américains les chinois
tente et bear et aux poussettes loyaux
déjà mangé trop vieux maintenant
merci merci merci à tous merci les
affranchis c'est le week end un profitez
bien très belle soirée documentaire
rester avec nous sur lcp
[Musique]